l'objectif de ces tarifs réglementés de
vente a changé en 2015 s'est inscrit
tout le monde peut aller regarder dans
les textes
l'objectif maintenant c'est un objectif
qu'on appelle de comté stabilité et qui
dit qu' il faut que ce tarifs
réglementés de vente soient suffisamment
élevés pour permettre à des fournisseurs
concurrents d'edf de faire des offres
moins cher que le tarif alors même la
même l'autorité de la concurrence a dit
mme enfin c'est quand même pas possible
on n'a jamais vu ça dans aucun autre
secteur ça veut dire qu'on fait du
tarifs réglementés de vente un prix
maximum pour permettre à n'importe quel
fournisseur y compris les moins
performants d'utiliser cette ce tarif
est donc pour faire ça on a chaud non on
a on a un dont on a changé le mode de
calcul des tarifs réglementés de vente
qui maintenant reflet la manière dont se
fournissent ces de son histoire
alternative qui n'ont pas de moyens de
production
donc c'est à dire qu' une partie est au
prix régulier d'une clé d'accès au
nucléaire sur lequel on va revenir je
pense et une partie est aux prises au
prix de marché et comme le prix de
marché a augmenté et bien les dernières
ou pour regarder ça sur les dernières
hausses de tarifs réglementés de vente
qui ont eu lieu celle de 2019 ya quand
même eu une augmentation de près de 8%
il ya eu encore 4 % l'année dernière et
là on vient de nous annoncer une
nouvelle hausse
quand on regarde les décisions de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
sur la raison de l'augmentation de ses
tarifs
ce ne sont pas les augmentations de
coûts d'edf c'est l'augmentation des
prix de marché donc c'est directement
lié aux prix de marché mais de toute
façon il peut pas en être autrement
le encore une fois le l'ouverture à la
concurrence n'a fait que rajouter des
coûts donc j'ai dit à des coûts
démarchage
enfin je veux bien qu'on essaye de
gagner un peu de performance sur tel ou
tel point enfin quand on rajoute des
équipes commerciales des démarchages
tout le monde a vu que c'était des
marchés extrêmement fréquent il faut
bien payer les gens quand on duplique
tous les systèmes d'information tous les
systèmes de facturation
quand on augmente énormément les
services juridiques parce qu'avant tout
les tous les échanges entre les îles et
les moyens de production le réseau
c'était des échanges inter entreprises
informelles maintenant ça devient tout
contractualiser et surtout quand on
augmente à nouveau les coûts financiers
il ya forcément il va falloir que
quelqu'un de paix mais au bout du compte
est ce quelqu'un c'est forcément l'usagé
qui maintenant est devenu client
[Musique]